Nobody moves!
It's a shame we have to ruin this moment.
Get on your knees,
both hands behind your head.
Don't dawdle.
This is the FBI.
You are all under arrest for smuggling
and illicit drug manufacturing.
Come here, Edamura.
You bastard.
You sold us out?
Now you've done it.
You're the ones
who said to protect myself on my own.
Don't do it!
Abbie.
Laurent.
-Edamura.
-Why?
Why did you shoot?
It was the right move.
-Stop this nonsense--
-Shut up!
Drop your guns and move!
I'll kill this woman!
Come on, get out now!
Hey Jawface, don't do anything strange!
Okay, we won't do anything.
Salazar.
Come, we're running.
Get somewhere far away
and restart your corrupt life.
This isn't for you.
It's for Tom.
Thank you.
Get down!